I'll tell you this: In any fight,...
...it's the guy who's willing to die who's gonna win that inch.
And I know if I'm gonna have any life anymore,...
...it's because I'm still willing to fight and die for that inch,...
...because that's what living is:
The six inches in front of your face.
Now, I can't make you do it.
You gotta look at the guy next to you.
Look into his eyes.
Now, I think you're gonna see a guy who will go that inch with you.
You're gonna see a guy who will sacrifice himself for this team...
...because he knows when it comes down to it, you're gonna do the same for him.
That's a team, gentlemen.
And, either we heal now as a team...
...or we will die as individuals.
That's football, guys.
That's all it is.
Now, what are you gonna do?